we go select a radio
shot paper inside jam supernova you know
what time is
not a given inside landlord on deck
this is my new ep series it's out on the
22nd and the 10th so yeah make sure you
go check that all right let's go
[Music]
shout out hold on not in her family
shy degrees you know what time it is
we're inside baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was the only one who saw the vision
[Music]
rematch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you could only jump on cause i jumped
off the door like you were already dying
i don't listen to albany three's bars
and i know that might have already
signed my calls tell me about best in
the city look at my slow scare you
already yeah
i don't have matters but i got bangers
swear that's all that matters
[Music]
[Music]
right now you know what time is big
video as well
we don't mess around out here
you know what i'm saying shout out
everyone is inside
shout out masterpiece on that one as
well
thank you thank you
was called proper
are we doing it properly
yes
whenever i pull off i'm the guy that you
don't want none of it can never beat me
that you're making fun of when it stays
on instagram and never come off thought
to myself i'm thinking wood up looking
back later like man could have wanna
know why they were things that you can't
cause i do all of the things you should
have ugly duckling girl still goose me i
made the up boy
that i don't like the look of the boy
might get rushed if you don't rush off
my g's in the cook with
[Music]
i've been killing this thing man's
proper my girls lovely i'm a gang proper
vivid living is proper trust me chad me
must be off your rocker baby is proper
trust me i can never talk to a copper
maybe doing this proper trust me ain't
no time to be a doctor we've been doing
this proper trust me i was in the same
class as harry potter maybe living in
this proper trust me surreal talk who's
gonna trouble me i spent no one like on
a ding looking at this boy when they
look at me that's what i got
they didn't want to let me in the door
[Music]
i've been killing this thing man's
proper feels lovely i might get proper
vividly is proper trust me try me must
be off your rocker we believe it is
proper trust me i can never talk to a
copper maybe dealing is proper trust me
ain't no time to be a thought
[Music]
tennessee enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
i'm still getting used to being outside
and running out of breath all the time
and if it keeps getting taken then if i
lose y'all can't wreck it and if you
keeps getting taken then you have a
little shock on wreck it hey where's the
cabbage heads inside
[Music]
[Music]
then you better look strong told them
already that
[Music]
come on
[Music]
radio waves
[Music]
okay then yeah we're gonna switch over
getting greens inside yeah
yeah
say what i'm saying
you know what time it is son
whoa yeah shout out
[Music]
been going hard in the pain i can tell
she's a psycho [ __ ] yeah like she ain't
if i'm born aboard a plane i want it all
i never wait five pills on a buckle make
it right make it rain run it up run it
up and run it up and go again say what i
want i ain't taking it back
circle smoke might go to the other side
waving the flag
she's shaking the bike
she's shaking the back
of the check i'll pick a check and i'm
making it back
[Music]
say
[Music]
feelings talking about how they're not
involved if you're not involved then go
with you over there not info
[Music]
i ain't trying to say it twice and it
just been told i know money's corrupting
it's all but i still need the world
twice in it in gold everyone's telling
me i'm next to blow ball
[Music]
serve more smoke i go to the other side
waving a flight
she's shaking a bike
she's shaking a bike
hook up a check of a check and i'm
making it back
yeah yeah i say what i want i ain't
taking it back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
flight
she's shaking her back
she's shaking her back
hook up a check look over checking i'm
making it bite
you know the levels oh it mad this
weekend come on
outside baby
shy everyone has been missing the live
music select a radio 20 years
hook up a check hook up a check and i'm
making it bite
yeah yeah say what i want i ain't taking
it back
so much smoke might go to the other side
waving
she's
this one is crazy again off the ep
go check the mini vid i could have spent
two more stressing not taking a yell as
a lesson in the kitchen smoking no feel
fair come last season with the dressing
took a little while to get my head right
while lord knows everybody else does my
heading i'm going to party with this
sexy thing cause the name i keep on
forgetting
for the money
[Music]
paintings all gonna date me again hoping
the power would save me again feel like
mine are going crazy again could never
get lazy again and one trip so wavy
again haters them can never face me i
can't call fuel like mine are going
crazy again oversight don't want to hate
me again paintings all gonna date me
again hoping the pod will save me again
feel like finally going crazy again
could never get lazy again and one trip
so wavy again haters then can never face
me i can't quite feel like mine are
going crazy again
got mine doing no dreams like i don't
want to be in the office got my
diminutive schemes like man i gotta
double up comments got my bellin on me
like where the hell we're putting these
croppers got my umbrella my team like
better look short for the coppers my
trips are bro like what are you good to
drive we just come from oh so first one
stop this ride
if you really want to smoke then why you
want insta life
might keep talking on snowboard man no
more than that i don't want to hit me
again paintings don't want to date me
again hoping upon where it saved me
again when i feel like when i go crazy
again could never get lazy again and one
trip so wavy again haters then can never
praise me i can't call for your life
crazy again after the oversight don't
wanna hate me again paintings don't
wanna date me again hoping the power
would save me again quite few like money
going crazy again could never get lazy
again and one [ __ ] so wavy again haters
then can never face me
going crazy again not in the playboy
known so well i just want the prize
don't bell heard the career that i'm
like oh well still on top can't take no
else somebody keep walking up the
mission but i'm sticking to the client
just like an israel telling we could go
hotel or motel as long as you promise
you she won't tell big bro telling me
i'm gonna go hell i told him i don't
really business i want to take a tesla
off the wish list that means taking mc's
off the hit list my contact is for no
chip lick brain tumor my effortless
sickness taught my my witness the
fitness punch up my mum threaten a
witness
[Music]
bigger but inside
[Applause]
scotty's called serious ep that was that
22nd of the 10th it's grease baby got
one more as well real quick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fake promises from mps nobody didn't get
enough love
but that's already big fats and they
know you're coming for the
five about tax lie by that gonna not get
that keep saying next year that i might
vote for none of these dudes for my fans
urban guests love by the middle
the football criminals working in
parliament the football criminals
working in banks watching the news come
believe what i'm seeing acting like
immigrants are human beings man's of
violence like man's english and i'd say
the lies know you're repeating got
backlash reporting revolution then they
said you're all right for the time being
think he's saying that britain is great
but i mean britain is big but no one
likes me
i can tell something ain't right it's
one minute to midnight
the world's effect in it i can tell
[Music]
ain't right it's one minute to midnight
yeah the rich got riches brexit nhsf
then they're not gonna mend it i know
money's corrupting us all war criminals
on my nose expensive i said after
purpose in charge everything that i've
ever said i meant it i just break the
rules i don't bend it might get malcolm
x expected
[Music]
it was
nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
midnight
[Music]
big of everyone
as it says y'all keep it running keep
running
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
big or serious cpr right now or i think
anyway at least big up
[Applause]